action my name is Dan Rose guard I'm a
designer and innovative from the
Netherlands and these are 10 questions
for Instagram that I really don't want
to answer but I'm gonna do it anyway I
never had a blog do something you hate
it takes a lot of time so you have an
idea like it's there it's right there
and then it takes months to make it
happen the fear of failing is always
there in your shoulder the curiosity is
also there so one need to find a balance
between it but it will always be there
you got to deal with them I would love
to make a place where people believe
again if you go during the triggers the
better side of yourself now just do it
don't be scared wake up early take a
swim it is the water reset you and then
you get to work and you work your ass
off I mean I diver I love to sort of
surrender to you on the water world it's
really amazing
[Music]
I hear people's all you're very
confident but when I do something new
I'm also always an amateur I don't know
but I want to know and I'm in that
process I would become an astronaut in
space but I'm gonna do it anyway
you